sur ces plateaux techniques du cfa des
métiers de l'aérien à toussus le noble
on apprend à entretenir ou encore à
réparer des aéronefs des métiers
techniques accessibles à tous
et pourtant les femmes représentent
seulement 20% des effectifs
l'idée de se faire que le mécanicien est
quelqu'un de grand costaud et que ça
aujourd'hui c'est un métier c'est un
métier qui est ouvert à tout le monde
nous avons des outillages nous avons des
moyens pour lever les les pièces etc
elles n'ont kid c'est un métier qui est
comment dire accessible à tous gabarits
on va dire et donc aux femmes
cette visite s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un concours national à destination des
collégiennes et lycéennes
il est porté par l'association air
emploi objectif faire évoluer les
mentalités et susciter des vocations
tels ont une visite en entreprise une
visite dans un centre de formation et
ensuite à doivent réaliser une bd sur le
thème les femmes et l'aéronautique
et elles ont un grand oral où elles
doivent restituer
leur visite comment ça s'est passé la
place de la femme
au sein de l'entreprise à
toussus-le-noble le cfa des métiers de
l'aérien accueille 240 élèves en bac pro
et bts j'ai trouvé ça intéressant après
c'est pas le métier que je voudrais
faire mais c'est sûr que c'est toujours
bien d'apprendre des choses chaque jour
n'ai jamais trouvé que s'il y avait des
métiers fait pour les hommes mais je
mettrais bien une femme faire ça aussi
je ne vois pas pourquoi il y aurait des
problèmes avec ça pour la rentrée 2010 9
le cfa des métiers de l'aérien propose
plus de 500 contrats en alternance sur
le site de toussus le noble dans les
yvelines et à bonneuil en france dans le
val d'oise des formations accessibles
dès la seconde générale